ordena las fracciones de menor a mayor
aquí tenemos tres fracciones y vamos a
decidir cuál es la más pequeña cual es
la de en medio y cuál es la más grande
entonces una cosa que podemos hacer es
observar estas fracciones pensar en lo
que significan y luego estimar siete
décimos digamos que podría representar
siete de tus diez amigos que visten
pantalones azules bueno eso es mucho
muchos de tus amigos visten pantalones
azules y luego para un tercio podríamos
decir que uno de tus tres maestras usan
lentes y eso no es tanto si solo una de
tres usa lentes no es la mayoría de ese
grupo así que aquí tenemos una fracción
que representa la mayoría del grupo aquí
tenemos una que no representa la mayoría
así que esta que representa la mayoría
del grupo probablemente es mayor podemos
comparar estas dos por estimación y ver
que está siete décimos es probablemente
mayor que un tercio pero luego tenemos
aquí cinco sextos y cinco de seis es la
mayoría del grupo nuevamente
pero será más grande esta mayoría del
grupo o la mayoría del grupo que es 7
decimos esto es mucho más complicado así
que lo que podemos hacer es tratar de
cambiar estas fracciones para que sea
más fácil comparar y así no tendríamos
que comprar décimos con tercios y con
sextos porque representan diferentes
tamaños grupos de diferentes tamaños
piezas de diferentes tamaños que
resultan difíciles de comparar así que
las queremos cambiar para que tengan el
mismo tamaño entonces necesitamos un
número que sea múltiplo de 10 de 3 y de
6 alguna por el que podamos multiplicar
10 3 y 6 para obtener un nuevo
denominador que funcione para todas
nuestras fracciones algo que me gusta
hacer es observar el denominador más
grande que es 10 y pensar en sus
múltiplos el primer múltiplo
es 10 porque 10 por unos 10 podemos
cambiar tercios y sextos para tener
decimos como denominador hay algún
número que podamos multiplicar por 3
para obtener 10 no lo hay así que
tenemos que continuar el 10 no funciona
el siguiente múltiplo de 10 es 10 por 2
que es 20 y de nuevo hay algún número
que podamos multiplicar por tres y por
seis para obtener 20 otra vez no así que
20 no funciona que tal el 30 vamos a ver
podemos multiplicar 3 por 10 para
obtener 30 así que el 30 funciona para
el 3 y vamos a ver si funciona para el
66 por 5 es 30 así que el 30 funciona
para que sea nuestro común denominador
30 vos 30 es un múltiplo de 10 de 3 y de
6 así que empecemos a convertir nuestras
fracciones para tener el 30 como
denominador
empecemos con siete décimos
queremos tener como denominador al 30
así que por qué número tenemos que
multiplicar 10 por 13 30 y siempre
multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por el mismo número
así que 7 por 3 es 21 entonces 7 décimos
es igual a 21 30 2 es igual
solamente cambiamos el tamaño del grupo
cambiamos el denominador para que sea
más fácil comparar pero no cambiamos la
porción del grupo que está representando
7 sobre 10 es la misma porción que 21
sobre 30 y vamos a continuar con un
tercio
nuevamente necesitamos que el
denominador sea 30 así que en esta
ocasión multiplicaremos 3 por 10 para
obtener 30 y el numerador también lo
tenemos que multiplicar por 10 1 por 10
en 10 10 sobre 30 es lo mismo que un
tercio si tenemos 10 personas de 30 que
usan lentes usaremos nuevamente ese
ejemplo o un tercio es el mismo tamaño
del grupo la misma porción y finalmente
5 sextos qué número tenemos que
multiplicar para obtener 36 por 5 es 30
así que multiplicamos el numerador por 5
y 5 por 5 es 25 entonces ahora en lugar
de usar estas fracciones originales que
es complicado comparar ahora tenemos
números que son más fáciles de comparar
tenemos 21 30 vos 1030 vos
y 25-30 vos
en este ejercicio las piezas son 30 bos
en todos los casos esto es mucho más
fácil de comparar simplemente podemos
mirar los numeradores y ver qué porción
de estos 30 representan cada fracción
así que la primera 7 sobre 10 es lo
mismo que 21 sobre 30 un tercio es lo
mismo que 10 sobre 30 bueno claramente
21 sobre 30 es una porción más grande
del grupo que 10 sobre 30 así que
estábamos en lo correcto cuando
estimamos aquí arriba que siete décimos
era más grande que un tercio pero luego
la más difícil que teníamos aquí arriba
ahora la podemos ver claramente 25 es la
porción más grande del grupo 25 es mayor
que 10 y que 21 entonces ahora podemos
listar estas fracciones de menor a mayor
la más pequeña es diez treinta bosch que
recuerden es igual a un tercio
así que ponemos un tercio como la menor
y la tachamos luego sigue 21 sobre 30 o
25 sobre 30 21 es menor y representa 7
décimos
así que podemos decir 7 decimos porque
21 30 vos es igual a 7 decimos y
finalmente nos queda 25-30 bosch que es
equivalente a 5 sextos así que de menor
a mayor
nuestras fracciones son un tercio siete
décimos y cinco sextos